Trading with indicators is useless.
Actually, it's worse than useless
because indicators are delayed metrics
that slowly destroy your ability to
truly understand what the market is
doing right now. In fact, I'd go as far
as saying relying on indicators is one
of the biggest reasons traders are stuck
losing for years. And I'm not
exaggerating. I don't say this lightly
either. I say this as a trader who has
been through that struggle and knows
exactly what it takes to stay profitable
in the long term. Now, here's the
problem. Most traders are taught from
day one that indicators are the answer.
That if they can find the right
combination of moving averages, RSI,
MACD, VWOP, volume, whatever it is, then
suddenly the market will make sense. But
if that actually worked, 90% of traders
wouldn't be struggling like they are.
The truth is, indicators don't actually
[music] give you clarity. They give you
false comfort. They make you feel like
you have confirmation, but all they're
really doing is showing you what's
already happened. And for most traders,
that's the trap. Now, some people might
say indicators aren't the problem. It's
a skill issue. that most traders just
aren't experienced enough to use them
the right way. And I disagree. You do
not need to be a genius to succeed at
trading. It's not some impossible task
to take a few highquality trades [music]
each week and have a positive outcome.
But there are entire industries built on
convincing you that the market is super
complicated. that you either need
someone else to manage your money or
that you need 12 indicators, you know,
five computer screens and a crazy market
data subscription to find the magic
combo that will really work out. So, in
this video, I'm going to show you
exactly why trading indicators put you
at a disadvantage from the start and
what you can use instead to trade
profitably over the long run and
actually build consistency. So, why do
indicators not actually work? Now, the
main reason indicators fail traders is
simple. Indicators are delayed. Every
indicator you use is built from one
thing, price. That's it. Indicators
don't predict price. They react to it.
They're math formulas layered on top of
what has already happened on the chart.
So, when you're waiting for an indicator
to signal to buy or sell or what
direction the market's going to go, it's
quite often too late. Think about it.
When price starts ripping higher, an
indicator won't catch it immediately. It
needs time. It needs candles. It needs
data to confirm what is happening. And
by the time it confirms, the move or
crazy at market action is already
halfway over. That's why so many
traders, and myself included, felt like
I was always chasing moves. you end up
buying at the top because the indicator
finally has turned bullish or you short
at the bottom because the indicator has
finally started said, "Oh yeah, you're
in a really strong downtrend." And
actually, the trend has already showed
signals that it's stopping and going to
turn around. And it's not because you
don't know what you're doing. It's
because indicators train you to react to
what the market is doing instead of
reading what the market is telling you.
Now, compare that to price action. Price
action is raw data. It's the market
speaking in real time. It's not
filtered. It's not delayed. It's not
gone through some crazy math formula and
interpreted in some specific way. It's
just buyers and sellers telling you
what's happening. If buyers step in
aggressively and a candlestick
skyrockets, you'll see it instantly
before the candlesticks even closed,
which what a lot of the times indicators
require. Price action is just telling
you what the market is doing. That's the
biggest misconception traders have. They
think indicators reveal something
hidden. But there's nothing hidden in
indicators. They are just a summary of
what price has already done. Price
action is the source. And when you learn
how to read the source, you stop needing
confirmation. You stop needing five
different tools to agree, getting
analysis paralysis, and missing good
opportunities, and you start actually
understanding what's [music] happening
and why it's happening. Now, this
doesn't mean all indicators are useless.
There are some good indicators that help
you quickly spot certain price action
signals that aren't necessarily based
off of a crazy math algorithm or delayed
metrics. and we'll go over those in a
minute. But overall, learning to just
read the price action will help you
avoid a lot of the traps that just
relying on indicators will cause. So,
over time, through all of this practice
with reading price action, I've realized
some of the best ways to profit in the
market are waiting for when it gets to
extremes. Because when extremes happen,
that's when the most money can be made
because it's overextended
so far in one direction that there is a
lot of traders that are either trapped
or getting too excited. And when a lot
of times things get emotional in the
market, people get on the wrong side.
And if you can be the opposite of that,
there's a ton of money to be made. Now,
think of the market like a rubber band.
If you stretch the rubber band farther
and farther, it builds more and more
tension, causing it to snap back to an
equilibrium state. The market works
exactly like this. In a healthy trend,
it needs to have pullbacks to stay in
more of an equilibrium. So, if it has a
move that doesn't have any pullbacks, it
increases the chance of it being
overextended out of weak [music]
equilibrium and it will likely have a
pullback the farther and farther it goes
in one direction. You can see this all
over the chart when you look at it. And
this gives a massive edge when it comes
to trading because you can risk a small
amount for a big potential profit. When
you lose, let's say you risk $100, you
lose $100. But when you win, you can
make three or $400 even if you have a
30% win rate, you are still making money
over the long run, which is all that
matters when it comes to trading. This
is where you can have indicators help
you. Once you understand the overall
patterns, you can use something called
the fair value gap indicator because it
just makes it easy to identify areas of
big reversal potential. Now that I've
added this to the chart, you can see
that it puts these red and green boxes.
And so every time there's a red box,
it's telling you that there is some
overextension to the downside. So right
here, there's a massive red box. It's
saying it's overextended to the
downside. And so things slow down and
eventually reverse that. Same thing on
the flip side, big green box. And so it
says, okay, this is a huge move where
the market's been overextended and it's
going to have to essentially give that
whole move back up at some point.
Sometimes it'll be really quickly and
sometimes it'll take a little while
before it eventually does that. But this
is how you can use indicators to easily
identify areas of opportunity where the
market in the future could make a
drastic move in one [music] direction.
Now, betting against a strong trend is
very, very risky. It's easy to jump in
too early. The classic phrase, the trend
is your friend, is really true. Don't
bet against the trend until it's clear
that it's actually over. So, over the
years, I've actually created a simple
checklist that helps you identify when
the current trend is over. And coupling
that with having the market being
overextended
makes it likely that it will reverse.
There are also specific times of the
trading day that this works the best
that I'll talk about in a little bit
too. And this is a strategy that I have
used for years now and have taught other
traders to become consistently
profitable with. And so this works for
struggling traders. Okay. So, step one
of this checklist that I've created over
years, if you're using the fair value
gap indicator, look for those big boxes
to show you and easily identify where
the market is extremely overextended in
one direction. This is that simple thing
of looking for those rubber band move
potentials where the market is way too
overextended in one direction. It's
becoming unhealthy and it's likely to
snap back at that point. If you don't
want to use the indicator, you can also
just look at the price itself. Just
looking at the trend of candlesticks
being very onedirectional without
pullbacks. A healthy trend needs
pullbacks in it. But if it just goes
down super fast or up super fast in one
direction, it's unhealthy. Now, to do
this, I either like to look at a
15-minute chart or a five-minute chart
[music] with these indicators to help
easily identify where these swings in
the market are that it's overextended.
This helps you dramatically stay away
from the noise and the choppiness in the
market and knowing that so you don't
lose a ton of money when the market's
just going to sit there or trend in one
direction and not be good for trading.
Now, step two, you want to see an
overextended trend into an area of
either resistance or support somewhere.
I like to use a clean rule of where the
market has already touched multiple
times. And this is looking at a larger
time frame chart than what you enter in
on. I like to enter in on a one minute
chart. And so I want to look at the
bigger swings in the market and draw
those levels off of them because this is
already pre-identified areas where the
market's come up here already twice and
failed. And so it's likely that it could
come up again and fail again. Now, other
key spots where the market might reverse
are either the high or the low of the
previous day or the open and the close.
These are other areas you're going to
want to watch because they can cause the
market to reverse. So step three, I like
to zoom in now to a one minute chart.
You want to look at and analyze the
current trend into that resistance zone.
And you want to make sure this current
trend that it's in is actually broken
and starting to show signs of reversing
because otherwise it's really easy to
see the start market start to slow down
and think this is where it's going to
reverse, but in reality it's just having
a healthy pullback before it continues
higher. Again, never bet against a
strong trend until it's confirmed that
it's actually reversing. There are so
many doom and gloom market predictions
all the time saying that a massive crash
is coming and it never happens. A trend
can last in one direction way longer
than you think. Wait for a signal to
show that it's actually reversing and
has the potential to go down and it will
save you a lot of money. Now, step four
is similar to step three. It's
confirming through the market structure
that the trend is starting to reverse. I
used to try and jump into the market
early hoping to catch something like a
VT top or a V bottom because when you
do, you'll feel like a million bucks,
but the losses often outweigh the wins
of trying to catch these Vbottoms. and
trying to figure out how to do that will
waste so much mental energy that it's
easier to just skip that type of trade
and wait for a more confirmed consistent
one. What you want to do is look at the
swings the market trend is having. A
downtrend is signaled by lower lows and
lower highs and an uptrend is signaled
by higher highs and higher lows. Well,
when it starts to shift, you will see a
lower low get made and a lower high get
made. This is called a break of
structure. This is a massive signal that
the current trend is slowing down or
stopping and a new trend is going to
start. Now, just because this happens in
an uptrend, that doesn't mean that all
of a sudden it's going to shift into a
downtrend. It could go into a sideways
trend or it could just continue in that
uptrend but in a slightly slower
version. [music] But the idea is adding
all these steps together increases the
likelihood it will bounce and you can
get a trade out of it or at least go
break even. Like in this case here, this
is showing a consistent uptrend until it
makes a lower low right here and then
[music] a lower high right here as well.
And it breaks this low, making it a new
low. At that point, it's showing you
that it's starting a downtrend and you
can capture a trade to the downside.
Now, I've just made a new strategy PDF
guide that you can download for free
that will give you a clear picture and
visuals of this entry checklist with dos
and don'ts of the strategy. You can get
it via this QR code or the link in the
description below. And the last step to
actually jump in on a trade, because
this is probably one of the most
important things to pull the trigger,
knowing where to finally enter can be
the hardest part of a trade because it
can make or break your trade. Even if
you have the right idea, I'm sure you've
had this happen before where you enter
into a trade and you get knocked out at
a loss, but the chart still goes in the
direction you are betting. That's
probably the most frustrating thing in
trading. So, picking the right entry and
stop-loss location is extremely
important. What I like to do is using
the swings in the market, look for a
break in the previous swing low if I'm
looking for a short after it's made a
confirmed lower high. So, this market
right here trends down, pulls back,
makes starts to make a lower high here,
and then as soon as the market breaks
this previous low, I would enter in for
a short right here and put my stop loss
above this swing high. So essentially, I
would enter in here with my stop up
there. That would be my risk. And then I
would put my profit target somewhere at
2 or 3x and wait for the market to trend
down and hit that profit target and call
it a day on that trade and move on to
the next one. And once you're in the
trade, you can manage it based on what
you see the market potential. This is
all about kind of zooming out and seeing
the big picture again of what you think
is possible. If you think there is a
massive swing down potential, you can
try and let the trade run a little bit
more so you can capture a big move
potential. Or if you think that it's
more likely to start chopping around,
you can go for two or three times your
risk as a good profit target. I do both
kind of depending on what the market is.
If there's a lot of volatility, I'll
give it a lot of more wiggle room and
I'll try and move my trailing stop as
the trade progresses. So, you're locking
in some of your profits, but if it's
kind of choppy and not so good, I'll
just go for a fixed two or three times
my risk. This is something that's a lot
harder to do until you really understand
price action and movement, but it's also
really, really powerful for maxing out
what you could get out of trades. Now,
the last thing is time of day. The most
volume in the market is in the first 30
to 60 minutes of the New York Stock
Exchange open. So, I watch for just 60
to 90 minutes a day and wait for an
opening spike to look for reversals
potentially when and if it hits
everything on my checklist. This allows
me to get in when there is movement and
it turns out to be a slow day, I can
just call it and wait for the next day.
Plus, sometimes if you catch that
opening move and it's the start of a big
trending day, you can capture a huge
trend over the day. Now, for this
strategy, you can trade it on any market
or time frame, but I focus on the S&P
500 futures and the NASDAQ futures. They
are super powerful for starting and
growing a small account. The trading
platform I've used to do this for the
past 5 years is called Ninja Trader. You
can check that out in the description
below or this QR code. Now, if you want
an even more detailed step-by-step
walkthrough with real trades of the
strategy and how futures can help you
level up your trading, check out this
video right here. It'll go through every
detail. Also, don't forget to get that
guide of this strategy in the
description below.